Today, we're going to be speaking with Jonathan
Cohn, who's a senior national correspondent at
Huff Post and also author of the book The 10
Year War, Obamacare and the Unfinished Crusade
for Universal Coverage. Great to have you on.
Jonathan, thanks for having me on the show.
So to start with you for a while, the way
that particularly the right but even sometimes
Democrats would talk about Obamacare was this sort
of like appendage on to what was there before,
which could be cut off and separated kind of
at any time. The language of what we can we can
repeal it and we'll put something else in place.
Correct me if I'm wrong, but we seem to be getting
beyond that to where Obamacare is no
longer this
kind of standalone appendage to the health
care system. And it's just more part of the
status quo. And it's it's becoming more of the
system that we would have to modify or work
off of if we want to do further changes. Is
my perception accurate as far as that goes?
Yeah, I mean, I think just by default, almost
when you have something that exist for as long
as the Affordable Care Act has existed, when
you when it's so entrenched in our system
now that to pull it out would be very hard. And
it's people have insurance that they rely upon.
The health care industry is now sort of reoriented
itself around having this program in place.
And so pulling it out now is you have
to pull out a whole bunch of wiring
that goes with it. And it's interesting
because historically, this is one of the
obstacles to passing reform, right. Is that
the status quo is always hard to change.
Well, now the Affordable Care Act, that's why it
was hard to pass the Affordable Care Act. That's
why it was such a fight and continued to be such a
fight. But now it's been around for 10 years. You
know, it's now it's part of the status quo and
it's hard to change. And I think you see that
in part by the behavior of the Republicans
who don't really talk about repeal anymore,
which, as you know, it wasn't that long ago.
It was it was all they could talk about.
Yeah. And sometimes I hear the criticism from
folks who believe that the Affordable Care Act
doesn't go nearly far enough. And I'm under that
umbrella to some degree. But but not you know,
there's certainly a spectrum within that.
Sometimes you hear the critique that Barack
Obama should have started at the position
of Medicare for all and then negotiated to
something that would have been better than what we
got. I don't subscribe to that exactly, because, I
mean, he wasn't for Medicare for all. It would be
unlikely to expect someone to start a negotiation
with a position that's not even their stated
position. But I do think that maybe there
would have been a way to to end up with a
public option, having chronicled the way that
this all came together. Is it unreasonable
for me to think that some other approach
might have given us a public option back in 2010?
So I wouldn't say unreasonable, certainly. I mean,
you can any critique is reasonable, and I think
reasonable people can debate about this. I will
say I'm very skeptical of that argument for two
reasons. So No. One, in studying the history of
health care, know there was a century of working
on this, basically, and almost without exception,
it was a failure. Reforming health care is really
hard, reforming it. And given the constraints of
the United States government, where the Senate and
the power of special interests is even harder for
the country politically was in a different place
10 years ago than it is today. I mean, I think a
lot of people who are more progressive minded
don't remember that the country the political
conversation was just a more conservative
conversation. We were still in the back end of
the Reagan era where everyone was very skeptical
of government and the only reason health care
reform got as far as it did, and I talk about this
a lot in the book, is that there was a real effort
for the 10 years leading up to the Affordable
Care Act. So the 10 years before the ten year war
by Democrats to really get together and say, look,
the only way we're going to get through this,
the only way we're going to overcome our past
failures is to all get on the same page. And and
Medicare for all was just not in the conversation.
It's not like it was a day where had been the
subject of a presidential campaign for two
consecutive elections where you had some visible
proponents who had a big grassroots movement
behind it. So, you know, if Obama had gone
in and sort of offering to do Medicare for all at
the beginning, I think just there would have been
the whole thing would have fallen apart. And in
terms of getting a public option through now,
obviously he did endorse a public option. He
ran on a public option. It was part of his plan.
At the end of the day, they took it out and a
lot of progressives felt like he never really
fought for it. And, you know, there is something,
you know, there's maybe something to that. I think
a lot of progressives felt like he could have
pushed harder. The flip side of the argument
is the votes were not there in the United States
Senate. There were a whole group of senators. And
also in the House, there were some there are some
conservative Democrats, although it was less of an
issue there. But in the Senate, you had a bunch of
conservative Democrats who would not vote for it
and they had no margin for error. They needed
every single vote. And there I don't it's really
hard to imagine a scenario where you could
get it through, especially given how opposed
to sort of the sort of most conservative members
of the caucus. I mean, when they got to the bill
and they were getting to the end, they got to
fifty five, fifty six votes. They couldn't get
Joe Lieberman. They couldn't get Ben Nelson.
Both Lieberman and Nelson were dead set against
the public option. And there were others
who were not so vocal about it but were
also against it. So I have a hard time seeing
how a bill passes with a public option in it.
Yeah, I mean that to a lesser extent. We saw this
with the 15 dollar minimum wage in the of it in
the recent covid-19 relief bill, where there
were some who were saying this is as simple as
overriding the parliamentarian and putting
the 15 dollar minimum wage. Into the bill,
but then it simply wouldn't have passed because
it doesn't it doesn't seem Democrats had the vote.
I mean, obviously Obamacare was was bigger
and changed in a more systemic way. A lot of
aspects of how the system worked. But sometimes
maybe people forget that there's still a lot of
a lot of very centrist Democrats in the Senate.
There are it's the same exact problem today. I
mean, and it's always those senators on the fringe
who have the leverage ultimately, and they have
the leverage. Let's remember why they have the
leverage. I mean, obviously, if you if you're
in a situation where whether it's you're going
for 60 votes or 50 votes and you have exactly
the number you need. So that's this. Let's let's
say today you have exactly 50 Democrats. You know,
obviously any one senator can object and sort
of hold up proceedings. And so they in theory,
have leverage. But at the end of the day, on the
Affordable Care Act, at least what happened was
the people who were in favor of reform, the
liberals, the progressives, they wanted this very
badly. I mean, this this was something getting
universal coverage or getting close to universal
coverage. It was you know, it was in their DNA.
It's why they got elected to Congress in the first
place. And the more conservative Democrats, a
lot of them I mean, they were in favor of it,
but, you know, they were that passionate
about it and they they would have been OK
dropping it or at least compromising to
something much, much smaller. And so,
you know, in a game of chicken, you know, who
wins is the one who's willing to kind of let
it let it all go and fall off the cliff or
have the crash or whatever the analogy is.
And, you know, the liberal Democrats in a
day weren't willing to let this thing die
and as a result, they had less leverage.
There's no question that there are some who
maybe understate or maybe under understand the
the good things that came from the Affordable
Care Act. And there's a list that probably
will ring a bell to many in my audience,
including establishing exchanges, the
preexisting conditions provision, people,
young adults being able to stay on their parents
insurance until age 26 and many other things.
On the other hand, when you see that premiums even
within the exchanges and me as a self-employed
person, you know, I have one of those plans.
The price of these premiums is going up in
a cartoonish way that dramatically outpaces
inflation and cost of living in all these other
things. It's it's hard to feel as though it came
close to doing nearly enough. What I'm curious
about is, does it help set up whatever the next
step is going to be? Like what? How does it serve
as a bridge to what so many of us know has to have
more done on it? Or are we really just starting
fresh again whenever someone decides to take
it up? Maybe it'll be this administration.
It's a bridge and I think it's a very big bridge.
I mean, I think, you know, it has put the building
blocks in place, a lot of the key building blocks
of what I would consider a working universal
health care system. Really. So, yeah, absolutely.
I mean I mean what I consider. How do you define
universal health care? Let's take a step
back. I mean, universal health care system to
me and I think is the sort of generally accepted
definition among people who study this. You know,
everybody has insurance, everybody has good
insurance. So they're not facing bankruptcy.
If they have big medical bills, they don't have
to work for care because of cost. And there's some
kind of principle that everybody can get insurance
regardless of preexisting medical condition. And
then there's some kind of control of costs. So you
keep the system from becoming too expensive. Now,
we're not we haven't fully realized any of those
yet. But what are the Affordable Care Act? Well,
first thing is it got 20 million people insurance.
So right away you've closed the gap significantly
to the number of people who don't have insurance.
You've put standards in place for what insurance
should cover. The standards aren't strong enough,
but they're stronger than what was before. Right.
Similarly, there's you know, if you're buying
on the exchanges, there is financial assistance.
There are subsidies. The problem is for a lot
of people, they haven't been big enough. And so
people like you are paying these crazy premiums.
So how do you build on that? Well, actually,
we're actually seeing that right now. The Biden
administration, the Democrats with covid bill,
actually took the first step towards that, and
which is they did throw a bunch more money into
that financial assistance. So those premiums will
come down, the out-of-pocket costs will come down.
They should probably come down further to
really get to a universal coverage system.
And by the way, now you need to start thinking
about people with employer coverage who have
high premiums and high deductibles. And what are
you going to do for them? Right. But, you know,
you've made progress. You've established this key
principle that everybody is entitled to insurance
regardless of preexisting condition. And those
are two very big building blocks of a universal
coverage system. So there's more to do. Yeah, but
you can certainly build on that. Now, whether you
build on that by just making the Affordable Care
Act more generous and opening up the exchanges to
more people. Or you say, look, what we really need
is some kind of public option that can eventually
grow into a Medicare for all system or we just
need to go to a Medicare for all system. I mean,
you can take. Those different paths to
universal coverage, but to me at least,
I feel like we've moved down that road regardless.
Yeah, the late Ouvea Rheinhardt, who's written
about this, has your definition of what we mean by
universal. It doesn't have to be Medicare for all.
And he talked extensively in his
his last book, I believe it was
about the way that that those systems could look.
I guess the maybe the zoom out is conceding all of
the things you said. If we make an Obamacare's
worth of progress every 11 years, we're a long
time from a system that many of us would consider
to be a system that's working really well.
Yeah, well, I would say, you know, I mean, that's
an interesting way to put it. I haven't quite
thought of it in that way. But, you know, if
you think about it, let's let's create a unit,
Obamacare unit that's a unit of progress.
Obamacare to Obamacare. So we just took an
Obamacare unit. And, you know, I'd say the
nineteen sixties, we took an Obamacare sized
unit with Medicare and Medicaid. Some people would
argue that was bigger. Someone also, smaller or
less, for sake of argument, say that was wasn't
Obamacare kind of leap. So I'm guessing maybe one
or two more of those leaps gets you there. Pretty
much. I mean, you know, we did close. I mean,
with this Obamacare leap cut the number of
uninsured in half, basically. So, I mean,
that's you know, that's a pretty big jump. I mean,
I think the problem with that, Jonathan, would be,
you know, listen, like as I'm going to tell my
audience in our next segment about a recent,
you know, interaction with the medical system,
I pay five, twenty, 20 a month for a silver
plan. I don't get a subsidy. I don't deserve a
subsidy. I can afford it. That's totally fine.
But there's a lot of people who also are much
closer to the edge on when they get a subsidy,
which would who would pay my same five twenty a
month and still
have a seventy five dollar copay and still have
a two thousand dollar Labbe deductible to meet.
It's completely unaffordable. So I feel like
for them to say simply 20 million more people
got care. Many of them are paying for the
premium, but they can't actually afford
to use any of the care. And that, I think,
is not in those numbers that that is. So,
you know, it's just, hey, we cut it in half.
Yeah. But a lot of those people aren't really
using the care because they can't afford to.
Sure. Sure. So the last thing I want to do is
to downplay that in any way. And I spent a lot of
time in the book talking about you do you do and
those people. So I completely agree. And it's why
we have so much more to do. I would say that it
is also true that for all the people who now
have insurance that they can't use, there are
a lot of people who got better insurance and got
cheaper insurance. And that also doesn't show up
in the 20 million. Right. But there are a lot of
people who were buying on their own who actually
now are paying less. And again, I do think these
enhancements that came with the covid relief bill
are going to make a difference because, I mean,
I don't know where you fall on this spectrum,
but one of the things it basically said to
everyone who's now buying on the exchanges,
if you're already buying subsidized coverage,
you're going to get a bigger subsidy. And if
you're one of those people who doesn't get a
subsidy, you might be eligible for one now. Now,
again, I think even when that's all done, this
insurance is going to be pricey for some people
and they're going to still be people who pay too
much. And again, I don't anyway want to downplay
that or say that's not a reason that we need to
act soon. But I do think, you know, it is sort of
you know, it's a tough kind of get across,
especially if you're a politician. But somehow I
need to get across the idea that we actually did
accomplish a lot and we still have a lot to do.
Yeah, I think that that's the best way to say
it. Much was done and much remains to be done.
And, of course, you know, in these next couple of
years when Democrats controlled the White House
and the Senate and the House of Representatives,
we'll see whether anything does get done. And
certainly what was in the covid relief bill also
shouldn't shouldn't be understated. The book shows
both sides and the book is called The 10 Year
War, Obamacare and the Unfinished Crusade for
Universal Coverage. We've been speaking with
the book's author, Jonathan Cohn. Jonathan,
I really appreciate your time today.
Thanks for having me on the show.